équilibré ces deux côtés, nous
dit Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau.
- Clara et Angélique ont 16 ans.
Elles ont commencé à travailler
à 15 ans, en pleine pandémie
- Je voulaororortir un peu
de la maison et en même temps,
je voulais me faire de l'argent.
- Elles jonglent avec l'école
et le travail.
- Dire non à son employeur
n'est pas facile compte tenu
de la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre.
C'est donc pour égégéger
les jeunes, de plus en plus
nombreux sur le marché
du travail, que Québec
veut légiférer.
JEAN BOULEinininistre du Travail
- Ça a provoqué une augmentation
aussi considérable du nombre
d'accidents de travail.
- Entre 2020 et 2021, la CNESST
a ueueueue les accidents
de travail chez les moins
de 16 ans ont bondi de 149
à 203, une hausse de 36 %.
Il faut également prévenir d d .
- Et on a réalisé qu'au-delà
de 15-16-17-18 heures, il y a
un risque de décrochage qui est
plus important. En plus,
ça provoque de la fatigue,
du stress, de l'anxiété.
- Québec recommenderait
l'interdiction de travailler
avant 14 ans, sauf exceptions.
Entre 14 et 16 ans, le nombre
d'heures de travail serait
restreint : 17 heures
par semaine pendant l'année
scolaire 1 1 1 10 heures maximum
du lundi au vendredi.
Les associations patronales
saluent le geste.
KARL BLACKBURN,
Conseil du patronat du Québec
- C'est une proposition
raisonnable dans un contexte
où la priorité est l'éducation.
Ça ne vient pas exclure
les jeunes du marché du travail,
au contraire, ça vient
simplement encadrer le contexte
dans lequel ces jeunes vont
pouvoir avoir accès au march
du travail.
- Pour Ève, qui travaille auprès
des jeunes, le projet de loi est
une excellente base, mais il
ne suffira pas à lui seul
à discipliner les employeurs.
ÈVE CYR, Carrefour jeunesse
emploi d'Hochelaga Maisonneuve
- Il y a déjà des lois
qui existent sur le travail
des enfants, mais souvent,
les employeurs soit
e la connaissent pas très bien
ou ne l'appliquent pas.
Une loi, c'est important,
effectivement, mais il f
la faire connaître, la faire
reconnaître.
- Pour que les employeurs
respectent les limites
des jeunes, comme Angélique
et Clara, qui